Donald Trump has been indicted in
federal court for illegally retaining
highly classified defense documents
obstruction of justice and a whole bunch
of other things it's his second
indictment and as you might have been
able to tell by the public reaction this
time everyone knows it's particularly
serious and it is it is bad it is beyond
that if even half of it is true then
he's toast for more than a year
prosecutors have been collecting
evidence about whether Trump knowingly
retained classified documents at his
Mar-A-Lago Resort in Florida after he
left office investigators looked at
whether he took steps to concealer
materials after the justice department
issued a subpoena for their return and
this included investigating whether
Trump instructed others to conceal the
materials and whether he revealed their
contents to other people and now we know
the answer the answer is yes he did the
most serious charge against Trump is
that he retained National Defense
information which is a violation of the
Espionage Act and now we have the actual
indictment itself I remind you that
these are unproven allegations and the
government will have to prove them
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt for conviction
but the doj says that they have a
mountain of corroborating evidence
including tapes emails texts and
Witnesses and the amount of verbatim
transcripts in this indictment makes it
seem like the doj has numerous
inculptory records of trump and his
staff so Trump's defense lawyers whoever
they are at the time of this video
should be quaking in their boots now the
indictment lays out in Lura detail how
Trump and his valet while team Naga
conspired to conceal government
documents the facts of the indictments
start on January 21st 2021 with Trump
getting ready to leave office Trump
caused his boxes containing hundreds of
classified documents to be transported
from the White House to the Mar-A-Lago
club from January through March 15 2021
some of Trump's boxes were stored in the
Mar-A-Lago club's white and gold
Ballroom Trump's boxes were for a Time
stacked on the ballroom stage now as an
attorney with years of experience I
probably need to break this down for you
lay people now generally speaking a
stage is used for the I don't know
public display of something and being on
a stage in a ballroom is usually
antithetical to the secure protection of
top secret documents so in March 2021
those boxes were moved to the business
center at Mar-A-Lago this location also
proved to be a problem as Trump employee
number one asked Trump employee number
two if they could move the boxes out of
the business center to make room for
staff to use it as an office employee
number two initially bulked at the
suggestion whoa okay so POTUS
specifically asked now to for those
boxes to be in the business center
because they are his papers but later
employee two suggested moving the papers
to the lake room to which employee one
responded there is still a little room
in the shower where his other stuff is
is it only his papers he cares about
there's some other stuff in there that
are not his papers could that go to
storage or does he want everything in
there on property this was a good idea
to employ number two yes anything that's
not the Beautiful Mind paper boxes can
definitely go to storage want to take a
look at the space and start moving
tomorrow am yes believe it or not his
staff actually called them the Beautiful
Mind paper boxes and so after the Texas
change between Trump employee number one
and Trump employee number two in April
2021 some of Trump's boxes were moved
from the business center to a bathroom
and shower in the Mar-A-Lago club's Lake
room so at this point the Beautiful Mind
paper boxes had slowly declined in
position and repute from the stage of
the white and gold Ballroom to the
modest Business Center and now sadly
relegated to living in the bathroom As
Trump would say like a dog yes our
nation's Secrets relegated to the
ugliest bathroom on the planet and by
now we've been poking fun at this but
note that in this bathroom there are
fresh towels and there's an empty waste
bin implying that the housekeeping staff
continually refreshes this bathroom and
I kind of doubt they have uh TS SEI
clearance but after a couple months
Trump apparently decided he needed to
use that shower and had the boxes moved
to a storage room and in May 2021 Trump
caused some of his boxes to be brought
to a summer Residence at the Bedminster
club and then it gets worse on December
7 2021 one nauda found several of
Trump's boxes fallen and their content
spilled onto the floor of the storage
room now detected Trump employee two
quote I opened the door and found this
now to also attached two photographs he
took of the spill from employee number
two replied oh no oh no and I'm sorry
POTUS had my phone and now to attached a
couple of photographs of the spill one
of which is given to us in the
indictment with visible classified
information redacted now apart from the
documents this is also an interesting
detail that POTUS had this employee's
phone uh Trump who famously does not use
a cell phone was using someone else's
phone for God only knows what but this
is also penis compared to the recorded
interview Trump agreed to give in July
2021 with two staffers and the publisher
and Ghost Rider of Mark Moto's
autobiography at his Bedminster Club in
New Jersey now For Your Entertainment
we've used AI to recreate Trump's voice
from the transcript this is not really
Trump's voice which I assume would have
been less comprehendable well with Mark
milley uh let me see that I'll show you
an example he said that I wanted to
attack country isn't it amazing I have a
big pile of papers this thing just came
up look this was him they presented me
this this is off the Record but they
presented me this this was him this was
the defense department and him wow we
looked at some this was him this wasn't
done by me this was him all sorts of
stuff pages long look hmm
wait a minute let's see here yeah I just
found isn't that amazing this totally
wins my case you know
um
except it is like highly confidential
yeah
secret this is secret information look
look at this you attack and by the way
isn't that incredible yeah I was just
thinking because we were talking about
it and you know he said quote he wanted
to attack country a and what you did
this was done by the military and given
to me uh I think we can probably right I
don't know we'll see we'll have to see
yeah we'll have to try to declassify it
figure out all yeah see as president I
could have Declassified it yeah
now I can't you know but this is still a
secret yeah now we have a problem isn't
that interesting yes I would say that's
interesting I would say it's interesting
to admit that you know that you could
have Declassified it before you left
office but didn't and now you can't and
I'd also say it's interesting that you
are intentionally showing these
classified materials to someone who is
not allowed to see them that's
definitely interesting and again broadly
speaking writers and Publishers usually
don't go hand in hand with the
dissemination of TS SEI information but
surely that was the only time that this
happened right I mean it's so blatant
and stupid there's no way he did it
another time right wrong wrong in August
or September 2021 when he was no longer
president Trump met in his office at the
Bedminster club with a representative of
his political action committee during
the meeting Trump commented that an
ongoing military operation in country B
was not going well Trump showed the PAC
representative a classified map of
country B and told the PAC
representative that he should not be
showing the map to the PAC
representative and to not get too close
the PAC representative did not have a
security clearance or any need to know
classified information about the
military operation just what an
incredible Tableau I'm going to show you
highly classified material but also
don't get too close because you're not
allowed to actually see it
and on top of it there is a non-zero
chance that one of the people shown this
information was Kid Rock yeah that kid
rock now in May of 2021 Nara realized
that Trump had some documents that
belonged to Nara and began demanding
their return so after half a year of
repeated demands on January 17 2022
Trump employee 2 and NADA gathered 15
boxes from Trump's residence loaded the
boxes and now just car and took them to
a commercial truck for delivery to Nara
now as we know these 15 boxes were not
everything that Trump had stashed at
Mar-A-Lago and Nara knew that too so it
referred the matter to the doj on May 11
2022 the grand jury issued a subpoena to
the office of Donald J Trump requiring
the production of all documents with
classification markings in The
Possession custody or control of trump
or the office of Donald J Trump now 11
days later Trump met with his lawyer
Evan Corcoran an unnamed Trump attorney
number two at their meeting Corcoran and
attorney two made the legally wise
suggestion that they fully comply with
his subpoena to which Trump responded I
don't want anybody looking I don't want
anybody looking through my boxes I
really don't I don't want you looking
through my boxes well what if we what
happens if we just don't respond at all
or don't play ball with them wouldn't it
be better if we just told them we don't
have anything here
well look isn't it better if there are
no documents then Trump like a white
story with a very clear implication
attorney he was great he did a great job
you know what he said he said that it
that it was him that he was the one who
deleted all of her emails the 30 000
emails because they basically dealt with
her scheduling and her going to the gym
and her having Beauty appointments and
he was great and he so she didn't get in
any trouble because he said that he was
the one who deleted them yeah so
literally misunderstanding what he
thought happened in the Hillary Clinton
case and then suggesting that one of his
attorneys do what he think happened just
incredible stuff but apparently Trump
related the story more than once that
day but anyway Trump agreed that Evan
Corcoran would return to the Mar-A-Lago
club on June 2nd to search for any
documents with classification markings
to produce in response to the May 11
subpoena however between Trump's May
23rd meeting with Trump attorney won and
Trump attorney two to discuss the May
11th subpoena and June 2nd when Trump
attorney won returned to the Mar-A-Lago
club to review the boxes in the storage
room now to removed at Trump's Direction
a total of approximately 64 boxes from
the storage room and brought them to the
Trump residence in some between May 23
2022 in June 2nd 2022 before Trump
attorney one's review of Trump's boxes
in storage room NADA at Trump's
Direction moved approximately 64 boxes
from the storage room to Trump's
residence and brought to the storage
room only approximately 30 boxes neither
Trump nor NADA informed Trump attorney
number one of this information so
basically Trump let Evan Corcoran
believe that Corcoran had turned over
everything to the FBI then secretly
Trump and naota had hit away at least 24
extra boxes in another room when
Corcoran sifted through the boxes in the
storage room Corcoran used the clear
duct tape to seal the red weld folder
with the documents with classification
markings inside Corcoran brought the red
World folder to Trump in the Mar-A-Lago
dining room and confirmed that he had
finished his search for classified
documents Trump asked did you find
anything is it bad good Trump and Trump
attorney won then discussed what to do
with the red weld folder containing
documents with classification markings
and whether Trump 21 should bring them
to his hotel room and put them in a safe
there during that conversation Trump May
a plucking motion as memorialized by
Trump attorney won he made a funny
motion as though well okay why don't you
take them with you to your hotel room
and if there's anything really bad in
there like you know pluck it out and
that was the motion that he made he
didn't say that so after this incredible
exchange Corcoran contacted the FBI and
told them that they were ready to hand
the documents over the next day Corcoran
and Christina Bob met with the FBI gave
them the set of documents that they were
aware of as well as the red World folder
full of classified documents and
Christina Bob falsely certified that a
diligent search had been conducted and
that they returned any and all documents
that are responsive to The subpoena but
the thing that really slaps you in the
face is paragraph 72 because before the
lawyers had made the search apparently
earlier that same day NADA and others
loaded several of Trump's boxes along
with other items on aircraft that flew
Trump and his family North for the
summer but in any rate the FBI realized
that they were still missing a ton of
documents and so they took the
extraordinary step of issuing a search
warrant against the property and
basically rating on August 8 2022 where
they found 102 documents with
classification markings in Trump's
office and storage room now as you can
probably already tell Trump is going to
need a good lawyer which he may not have
right now because they keep resigning
but if you need a great lawyer my firm
the eagle team is now accepting new
clients if you've been in a car crash
suffered from police brutality or sexual
harassment or just about anything else
we can represent you or find the right
attorney who can so just click on the
link that's down in the description for
a free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team the link is below
and the timeline here is damning on May
11th Trump's lawyers accepted service of
the grand jury subpoena for the missing
documents on May 22nd NADA took one box
from the storage room and moved it to
the Trump residence the following day on
May 23rd Trump met with his lawyers to
discuss the response to the subpoena
Corcoran and Trump attorney too informed
Trump that they should really have the
chance to search the documents and make
sure that they comply fully with the
subpoena Trump clearly hated that idea
and expressed that he didn't want anyone
looking through through his documents
and eventually he agreed that Corcoran
would have to look through the boxes of
documents but he pushed that back to
June 2nd but before that on May 24th
NADA removed three boxes from the
storage room on May 30th after speaking
with Trump on the phone NATO removed 50
boxes from the storage room from a text
conversation between NADA and presumably
Melania Trump we know that the boxes
ended up in Trump's residence on June
1st the day before Corcoran search NADA
moved another 11 boxes to the residents
for a total of 64. and the following day
Nana moved only 30 boxes back from the
storage room for Corcoran to actually
look through it appears that both Trump
and NADA interacted with Corcoran the
day of the search and neither told him
that most of the boxes weren't in the
storage room basically they conspired to
make sure that Corcoran and Christina
Bob unwittingly lied to the FBI the next
day and only turned over a portion of
the documents now we'll talk about the
legal charges in a second but in some
the indictment hits every formal and
informal defense that Trump has so far
broached he possessed National Defense
information much of which was tssci he
didn't have permission to possess the
documents he did not secure the
documents he certainly didn't declassify
them he knew he had not Declassified
those documents that he possessed he
showed them to others he knew he
shouldn't show them to others he didn't
cooperate and then he lied that he had
cooperated he lied to his attorneys he
deliberately hid the docs from his
attorney so they couldn't comply he
repeatedly hid the docs from the FBI and
Nara and he conspired with others to
complete everything that we've talked
about and as the allegedly recorded
interaction show he did everything for
the trumpiest reason of all he kept the
documents and he showed them to others
for clout so by now you're probably
getting the sense that Trump is pretty
screwed but how screwed is he well the
indictment contains 38 different charges
and the first is 31 counts of violating
the Espionage Act one for each of the
documents containing National Defense
information the end time includes a list
of each of those documents which you can
find beginning on page 28. the list
includes documents marked top secret
special handling relevant to USA f v e y
for the five eyes intelligence uh top
secret and Si and in the descriptions of
these documents there are some truly
terrifying commentary on the nature of
these documents uh for example document
9 concerns military attacks by a foreign
country document 12 pertains to the
projected Regional military capabilities
of a foreign country and the United
States document 19 involves the nuclear
capabilities of the United States and
all these documents were according to
the indictment shuffled around various
locations in Mar-A-Lago squirreled away
in closets and bathrooms and stored next
to a toilet spilled on a floor and most
of the time easy for anyone who worked
at Mar-A-Lago to access and worst these
may not even be the most sensitive
documents recovered by the federal
government to bring an Espionage Act
case prosecutors have to cite documents
that can be partially revealed during
the trial that's because the defendant
has a right to review the evidence that
is being used against them so the doj
appears to have recovered at least 13
top secret documents that weren't
charged in the indictment for each
document listed in the indictment
prosecutors would have to have received
approval to use it in the criminal case
from the agency which owned that
information and some of the 13 documents
might have been considered too sensitive
to be exposed during the criminal case
and the indictment says that Trump kept
classified documents created by or in
some way involving most of America's
intelligence agencies including these
Central Intelligence Agency the
Department of Defense the National
Security Agency the National geospatial
Intelligence Agency the national
reconnaissance office the department of
energy the department of state's Bureau
of intelligence and research and others
now the name Espionage Act evokes
foreign spies and that has of course
triggered Trump and his supporters who
claim this act can apply to a former
president but the Espionage Act applies
to anyone who discloses National Defense
information to a foreign government but
it also applies to anyone who retains
National Security information or
discloses it to any unauthorized person
and that doesn't necessarily need to
even be classified information so
accordingly Trump was indicted under
Section 793 e of the ACT which makes it
a criminal offense for any unauthorized
person to willfully retain National
Defense information and fail to deliver
to an officer or employee of the United
States who is entitled to receive it a
793 e-offense is a felony punishable by
imprisonment of up to 10 years in prison
and unlike a lot of the things that we
talk about on this channel where the
maximum is nowhere near what the actual
sentence someone would actually get this
is something where 10 years might
actually be reasonable and the really
scary thing for Trump is that sometimes
these kind of offenses can get
consecutive sentences rather than
concurrent which means that they stack
on top of each other and have to be
served one after the other instead of
serving all of the sentences at the same
time that can add up really easily
that's not to say he's guaranteed
consecutive sentences there's a whole
thing in the sentencing guidelines that
I'm not going to go into right now but
it is a possibility now on top of that
count 32 is for conspiracy 2 obstruct
Justice sub session K of section 1512
purpose of conspiracy stating whoever
conspires to commit any offense under
the section shall be subject to the same
penalties as those prescribed for the
offense the commission of which was the
object of the conspiracy and here
Trump's co-conspirator was allegedly
walled NADA the indictment says the two
men pressured other witnesses to
withhold testimony or withhold a record
document or their object from an
official proceeding in violation of
section 1512 b2a and to corruptly
conceal a record in violation of section
1512c1 now count 33 of the indictment
charges Trump and NADA for misleading
Trump's lawyers and others in order to
withhold documents from an official
proceeding the purpose of this tampering
was allegedly so quote Trump could keep
the documents that he had taken with him
when he left the White House and to hide
and conceal them from the grand jury
count 34 is for corruptly concealing a
document or record in violation of 1512
c one and two and that section applies
to whoever corruptly Alters destroys
mutilates or conceals a record document
or other object or attempts to do so
with the intent to impair the object's
Integrity or availability to use an
official proceeding now here now to in
Trump were hit with this charge for
hiding and concealing boxes of
classified documents from Corcoran so
that he would not be able to return them
from the government then the 35th charge
says that the defendants were concealing
a document in a federal investigation in
violation of 18 USC 1519 which out lines
the federal crime of obstruction of
justice for destroying altering or
falsifying records and the indictment
lays out all the ways that Trump had now
obstructed the investigation Trump
suggested that his lawyer falsely
represent that Trump did not have the
documents responsive to The subpoena and
as we discussed in my video on the
attorney client privilege prosecutors
were able to use the crime fraud
exception to get access to the notes
taken by Evan Corcoran one of Trump's
lawyers and the man who is throughout
this indictment labeled as lawyer number
one uh corcoran's notes helped the
government lay the foundation for the
obstruction charge and the notes were
taken contemporaneously with events that
they unfolded the notes say that Trump
said quote I don't want anyone looking
through my boxes I really don't I don't
want you looking through my boxes which
is of course incredibly ironic and
hearkens back to my favorite part of the
Mueller report where Trump was talking
about how much he loved his old lawyer
Roy Cohn who was just a real piece of
work and hated the fact that his lawyers
were taking notes the president then
asked what are these notes why do you
take notes lawyers don't take notes I
never had a lawyer who took notes began
responded that he keeps notes because he
is a quote real lawyer and explained
that notes create a record and are not a
bad thing the president said I've had a
lot of great lawyers like Roy Cohn he
did not take notes yeah so here's the
thing real lawyers take notes both for
the client's protection and for the
lawyer's protection but uh I digress
anyway on May 23 2022 Corcoran and the
person described as lawyer number two
told Trump they needed to search for
documents responsive to The subpoena
Corcoran then told Trump that he would
be back on June 2nd but on June 1st
Trump spoke with Corcoran to confirmed
that he was coming to Mar-A-Lago on June
2nd and Trump directed naota to move 64
boxes out of the storage room and hide
them from the lawyers now to move the
boxes from storage room and put them in
Trump's residence on June 2nd the
lawyers searched the residence and they
found 38 classified documents and sealed
them in a folder but according to
corcoran's notes Trump told him wouldn't
it be better if we just told them we
don't have anything here he then said
well look isn't it better if there are
no documents
just classic stuff there and then of
course there was the classic plucking
gesture that he made about about the
documents now the government says this
obstructive conduct did Serious harm
because it meant the U.S didn't get the
documents back until at least August of
2022. that's worth noting the justice
department closed the Mike Pence case
without charging him for obstruction and
this indictment shows why Pence
cooperated with the government whereas
Trump instructed his aides and lawyers
to conceal records from the government
after Trump was on notice that the
government wanted them back he pretended
to be cooperating fully while trying to
keep the documents and it causes lawyers
to file a certification with the FBI
falsely stating that he did a full
search and returned all responsive
material so it's not surprising that
NADA was charged as his co-conspirator
in most of this conduct and Trump was
also charged with violation of 18 USC
1001 section 1001 is the classic don't
lie to the government provision it makes
it a crime for any person to make a
false statement orally or in writing to
Federal investigators it states that
whoever in any manner within the
jurisdiction of the executive
legislative or judicial branch of the
government of the United States
knowingly and willfully falsifies
conceals or covers up by any trick
scheme or device immaterial fact makes
any materially false fictitious or
fraudulent statement or representation
has committed a felony punishable by a
fine imprisonment by no more than five
years or both now the government accuses
both Trump and NADA of a scheme to
conceal the government charged Trump
with a subsection A2 of section 1001 by
making representations that are
materially false fictitious or
fraudulent and the indictment says that
he caused his attorney number three who
we think is Christina Bob to submit a
sworn certification to the FBI the
diligent search was conducted and that
all responsive documents were produced
with the certification in reality though
Trump had sabotaged the attorney's
efforts to do the search by making sure
that now to have removed boxes before
the attorneys even did their search and
that the lawyer wasn't aware that NADA
was concealing documents of course it's
their own problem that the lawyer did
not make sure that a diligent search had
been conducted but the indictment says
that after the June certification over
100 documents with classification
markings were recovered when the FBI
raided Mar-A-Lago NADA was also accused
of lying to the FBI violating the same
section of the law and count 38 says
that he voluntarily talked with the FBI
on May 26 2022 while represented by
Council and during the interview he made
the following false statements in
violation of 1001. he said he was
unaware of trump bringing any boxes into
his Mar-A-Lago Suite that he had no
information at all about where the boxes
were located how they were kept or who
had access to them he had never seen the
boxes until the day they arrived from
Pine Hall and the diamond says that NADA
knew exactly where the boxes came from
since he himself had moved the boxes
from storage and since now to had
reviewed the boxes in and around
Mar-A-Lago even taking a photo of their
spilled contents and sending it via text
message the indictment contains numerous
text messages from now to about fetching
the documents for Trump and on January
22nd 2022 now detected a Mar-A-Lago
employee about getting new covers for
the boxes because Trump thought the
existing ones were too marked up and
again this was all after Trump was on
notice that the government requested the
return of the classified documents
believing that they were in an unsecured
location and again here is nada who
doesn't have a security clearance moving
boxes around it will and then lying to
the FBI about it so basically if the
facts are as they are alleged the
justice department had no choice but to
indict now as well now one of the more
interesting things here is that Trump
wasn't charged for retaining material
that was returned to the government
prior to the 2022 subpoena so this is a
pretty good indication that if Trump had
cooperated like others who had documents
accidentally in their possession like
Biden and Pence and shipped everything
back he wouldn't be staring down the
barrel of 37 counts of this indictment
of course storing hundreds of top secret
documents in an unsealed bathroom can
lead to all kinds of information being
leaked but for most of us a lot of our
personal information has already been
gathered online but you can get your
online personal data taken down with
today's sponsor in cogni now I don't
know about you but I've seen a huge
uptick in the amount of spam that I'm
getting and it's no surprise why every
year the number in scope of data
breaches worldwide is rising and you
might not know it but there are hundreds
of data Brokers that possess and sell
your personal information and their
numbers are growing every year these
data Brokers could have your name your
address your phone number shopping
habits possibly even your social
security number all for the highest
bidder and best this leads to scam calls
and a worst identity theft or doxing and
that's where incognit comes in because
incogni fights on your behalf to remove
your personal data from data Brokers and
deals with any objections from their
side I've seen this in person it's
really impressive all you have to do is
create an account and give them approval
to work on your behalf and cognitive
then conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the broker removes your
data once they could collect it again
and incognitive makes sure that your
personal information stays off the
market for good when I signed up I saw a
huge decrease in number of spam emails
and calls that I was getting and it was
terrifying to see exactly how many
Brokers had my data but it was really
fun to watch incogni get them to delete
that info one by one so if you'd like to
give incogni a try click on the link
below to get 60 off of incognito when
you use the code legal eagle again to
get an exclusive 60 off discount just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description and use
the code legal eagle after that click on
this box over here for more legal eagle
or I'll see you in court